joining me now is Texas lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick governor thank you
so much for being here with us
first and foremost sure Jim for two
people that lost their lives and and we
have to not skip past that those are
families that are grieving in a church
in a community yes that should have
never happened and god bless those
people I I I hope we do proper justice
to their memory and wish him Godspeed
yeah
Jason look there were three heroes here
Richard white was pulling his pistol
attempting to take down the killer whose
name we won't mention and Tony Wallace
was standing there didn't have a chance
to defend himself at all and then Jack
Wilson that you saw and for people who
know firearms it's one thing to go to
the shooting range Jason as many of us
do in Texas and other places in America
and be able to fire a shot at 10 or 15
yards on target it's another thing when
someone's pointing a shotgun at you when
the adrenaline is flowing and he took
that in six seconds it was over you see
there are a lot of people in this
country led by the Democrats and the
radical left and Joe Biden who highly
criticized our law when we passed it to
allow members to conceal carry in church
to allow churches to have their own
security force we passed those two bills
in the last two years in Texas and we
know governor let me but let me let me
jump in there because you're right first
of all that shot was amazing and it
comes with you know a memory and great
training right and having the guts to do
it and being the right person at the
right time the second part is the
ability and the thought and the
preparation that church has but you're
right Joe Biden took a position and was
chastising the governor of Texas for
this we have the sound of that watch
this it is a rational with all due
respect to the governor of Texas
irrational what they're doing we're
talking about
Slean access to have guns be able to
take him into places of worship store
the new school I mean it's just
absolutely irrational governor rather
but I have a message for for Joe Biden
we passed that bill all the Senate I'm
proud of it Senate bill 635 and said
bill 2065
and let's let's be very clear to the
American people that Joe Biden is
dangerous he's not just an idiotic
person who says impossible absurd things
and he's not just naive but he's
dangerous Americans who have to
understand whether you both but whether
you believe in only a gun or not owning
a gun that the Democrats are dangerous
if they get elected to the White House
they will pass executive orders to take
your guns take your ability to protect
yourself your family your property and
your friends as those men did yesterday
it's idiotic to say to the American
public that we want to take your guns
and that's gonna make people be better
there's evil in this world Jason there's
darkness and there's light and we all
know it and that was evil yesterday and
first responders god bless them they
were there within a minute but this was
over in six seconds and if Jack Wilson
had not taken down that killer there
could have been 10 or 15 people killed
before the police got there oh no no you
idiot response it's the citizens
response that's the most important to
stop these shooters that's right now
explain to the viewers at home what was
the law that Texas changed and what did
that church do in preparation we've got
a short amount of time but explain to us
what changed at that church very quickly
so after the Sutherland shooting at that
church several years ago I asked the
Attorney General Ken Paxton if indeed
the law allowed us to conceal carry as
it was written and he gave an opinion
back to us in the Senate and said yes if
the church allows it now the church like
any other private institution or private
business proposed to sign and say you
can't I have not found a church yet
whose posted that sign there may be
somewhere but they know that they're
their men and their women in there are
going to be well trained their own
security volunteer team
some are off-duty police officers and
sheriff's deputies and they're going to
protect their congregation and they're
going to protect the pastor's look you
Jason people who don't know past
personally don't know how many threats
they get don't know how many threats
they get this pastor had been threatened
I talked to him last night
pastor farmer had been threatened by
this guy before and so he came in he
came in in disguise they were watching
him but you know you can't pull your gun
first you have to react and he pulled
his shotgun out from under his coat and
Jack Wilson reacted as did Richard was
the Richard white was killed Jack Wilson
took him down so that's the law we
change that you can carry if a church
allows him listen Jack Wilson I I cannot
say enough good things here about
ordinary people who do extraordinary
things and god bless him he saved a lot
of people that day governor lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick thank you for your
leadership and thank you sir for joining
us a happy new year